die ganze zeit über außen rum gehen halt
ganz entspannt du legst bei mir gerade
steht bei mir immer noch am anfang ich
guck mir das einfach mal an erzähl mal
weiter
oder auch den autos den musikern genutzt
für den zaun
oh wie schön ist milow den asta ehrt den
asta york city -stars sobald ob du hier
besondere ich sage ich dir geht weiter
ich weiß ja quelle dass das hier von
haus zu haus oder du gehst das bak
erstmalig macht nämlich summen da so
rein und sagt ihr denn da die straße
oben im haus von ihm ist ein richtig
geiles bettes hab ich gebaut als kind
einmal vor dass einem das maßvolle gibt
ihr gleich nur wolle
ach so das ist hier dieser komische
sound ich habe gerade im komischen
höhensonne gehabt wenn ich natürlich den
er meinte deinen sound
ach so ja er meinte mein sound
das ist hier ein paar wobei ich das hier
nicht als bunker bezeichnet sondern als
st doch das mit random glücken
aufgefüllt wurde
minecraft bagdad das hier gebraut sieht
sehr schön aus
die toll aus was dieses tank noch das
soll die nächste farben werden wenn du
das meinst ich meine diese leute hier
diesen bunker
ach so dann gehe ich mal weiter ich habe
das hier hinter ist auch nichts mehr
und er ist im vergleich zu dem was ich
an meine hütte aus sehr wichtiger
partner ist das meinte ich diese zone
aussteigen die überzeugen mich gerade
richtig
sind diese würde man sagen man würde
sagte schauen uns ja nicht dabei war man
di luca gebaut hat nach das immergut
chef ist einfach produktiv 30 17 jahre
an der farbe krieger ein nein danke oder
sie ja vielleicht auch finnische
neumodischen namen hast wirklich mal das
schaf gewissen größer machen die platte
richtig gebunden
ich weiß ich habe einen vorhin 10 ein
xbox dachte ich mir so nah kommt dass
man nichts mehr von meiner wohnung jetzt
ist hier manchmal springs auf 414 hühner
aus einem haufen geworfen geworfen nicht
kommt dann aber fit ich bei der feier
vier hühner aus einem teil auch einfach
gelegt nein das ist so locker wie tiefer
nein es ist das gab schon früher vor den
red drops aber ich meine generelle aus
einem hütchen kommt wirklich vier ja
wirklich hier
das habe ich niemals erlebt und ich hab
schon tausende arbeitskräfte frau
schauen die minecraft wirklich schon
tausende von meilen eine chance aber
gibt's also das hier ist auf jeden fall
der gang vor luca gewesen sehr tief in
die in den boden und hier sieht es in
münchen
ja das ist nicht töten dass mein haus
nun dass du auch mal das ist doch dieser
szene hätte genau deswegen das euch
gemacht wie oft hast du den obergrenzen
gehabt einem oder zwei mal einmal als
ich habe einmal die sind halt zwei mal
zwei gemacht hatten und dann aber den
fenster- und zweimal zu den jetzt noch
mal danke nochmal anderen oder sein
genau dann ist das so ein auge das
häufig dieses movie ganz gut das passt
mit dem mit der wolle dann mache ich
oben noch irgendeinen anderes material
ich weiß nicht was ich oben erst jetzt
sieht wirklich gut aus also was kann ich
da oben machen ja für einen keller geht
schon was kann ich denn da sind richtig
gut aus an deinem text apec
das richtig gut aus also gefällt mir
wird mich ein bisschen rum für luca
gefällt mir am besten du machst du
selber oder fragst du wo du bist ja
keine ahnung weil ich muss noch ein
bisschen was hingegen hat noch erd- oder
so muss bei mir ist ich hab nur essen
dabei weil ich habe alles kombi zu hause
gelassen
solche waren wir schon ich würde sagen
wir lassen das jetzt erstmal mit dem
thema für diese folge weil cavs
herumführen und dann muss eine menge
erzählen so tätig ist ja glaub ich nicht
mehr viel ist nur ein haus am spot das
war's dann könne theoretisch zum thema
sagen kernthema habe ich die auswahl
wähle ich mir hier raus wenn wir zu
wenige immer wieder ein einfaches thema
und zwar von gianni 2008 mehr bock auf
kompliziert ist nein du bist 40 uhr
thema denglisch konsolenspiele erstes pc
spiele pc konsole
es gibt vorteile konsole kommen die
spiele für pcs mit freunden spielen wenn
die da sind das finde ich ganz cool
ja ist ob die pc auch formel 1 212
splitscreen auch im pcb die firma finde
ich dann wieder blöd wenn man sich dann
zu zweit von pco platziert man sich die
cdu kann sehr trotzdem irgendwo
hinsetzen
ja aber ich uns auf der konsole
allgemein einfacher seine konsolen pcs
pc stellen einen pc machen die chance
sondern alles machen aber es geht auch
so deswegen finde ich es am platz an
einer konsole einfach besser aber jetzt
manche spieler wirklich nur für konsole
gibt wie zum beispiel uncharted heavy
rain halo was meiner praxis soll das
seit acht jahren sieben dieselbe konsole
das heißt 040 weiterentwicklung noch
dieselbe grafik wie damals natürlich
auch physik mäßig und augen gameplay
mäßig dieses ganzen einschränkungen
genau immer noch so wie damals blut blut
und das hält die ganze entwicklung
anfangs richtig geil
bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte
ja ja kommt runter einen beitrag noch
nicht zu geben
ich finde beides hat vor und nachteile
es gibt gewisse spiele nur auf pc
gewisse spiele nur auf der konsole dann
muss man wirklich seinen favoriten finde
ich meine ich es wirklich meint auch
beides gleich aber ich bin zum beispiel
groß geworden ich kann mich gar nicht
mit der konsole identifizieren ich habe
zwar damals durch fifa und was ich was
man sagt aber ich bin nicht so der wenn
man ein holz einfach so rein tut kriegt
man sofort ein stone button ja und 164
homebutton gemacht dass ihn ein rein
getan als letzte chance gegeben werden
uns damit holt sie mir bitte ein paar
sex wenn es geht
16 ab an die frische luft was aber
erstmal schlafen baut ihr könnt ja erst
mal bevor wir wirklich denn man könnte
ja mein haus kurz einmal besichtigen wo
es dunkel wird dann sieht geil aus
brauche ich dann nicht mehr zurückkommt
erbitte ich lade euch ein ja gleich dass
ich bei meinem song komm mit ich leider
gerade in minecraft
ich habe keinen plan was ich lag auch
ich glaube dass alvarado
ich lege nicht dann kommt heraus ihr
sollt nicht schlafen gehen könnt ihr was
abbauen
es geht es wieder keine ahnung was er
gemacht und schlug ihr dann schauen wir
uns kurz ein haus an
er wollte jedoch nicht da kannste mir
auch eigentlich schon die schaufel
zurückgeben weil wir dazu werden noch
fünf jahre schlafen
ich schaffe ein bisschen was zu fahren
kommst du felix bisschen am lernen da
kann ich jetzt noch schlafen ich hab da
eine aufnahme dann wir schlafen doch gar
nicht darf nicht wir zeigen nur ins bett
gelegt welches laut bin ich bestimmt
gleichen bett
ich lege echt total ich kann nicht
abbauen und so keine ahnung
egal dann zeigt man muss hier nicht viel
machen wir hier ist was schönes ambiente
wie macht man sich blumentöpfe mit sowie
drei masten mit gebratenen leben ok
kirche kannst halt über außen rum gehen
halt ganz entspannt denn du legst bei
mir gerade steht bei mir immer noch am
anfang ich guck mir dann einfach mal ein
weiter pass bloß auf mit den krippen
jetzt ach du scheiße ich bin plötzlich
im bett ich bin voller geflogen das mal
kurz rausgehen ich starte den server neu
was ich bin fit machen
warte ich glaube ich auch wieder rein
das problem ist nur kurz das loch einmal
wie sie mal auf dasselbe immer noch wir
machen jetzt ganz das was gesagt es hier
einmal anschauen was soll ich das
monster ich muss ja aber das loch zu
machen weiter und die elbe darüber
werden ganz privaten noch rein geknallt
hast du damit mir die ehre geben kann
oder damit ich das locker zu machen dann
fahre ich die erde war so was machst du
machst du da dann holzt unter nicht erde
ja weil ich nicht ewig nicht mehr erde
habe das war alles was ich habe ich rede
zu machen als echten restart 9
heute trafen das funktioniert alles den
jetzt alles funktioniert will einsamen
zurzeit noch 30 leute bei mir und klasse
ich kann nicht auf den server doch jetzt
ganz wiederum jetzt kann ich darauf
anmelden rhein direkt mehr als davor ja
jetzt perfekt
es läuft bei mir im boden naja dann
springen raus aussehen wurden bin aber
nicht im boden bei mir jetzt gemeldete
meine erde meine schaufel den ärgert ich
habe eine erde ich doch nicht jeder geht
um rieckhoff
oder gibt mir sind das ja noch so
gewesen
das kleine bild halten ich habe gerade
ganz wunderschön ein paar schilder an
der wand bisschen in eine richtung
das fleisch sie richtig saftig aus hier
ich brauche mehr sense dem auch sand am
meer in richtung volt stellt noch nicht
machen
er hat ein haus sagen wird echt schön
aus
wir haben noch zwei minuten floh nie
mehr geben wir ja keine stadt kiste was
ich auf jeden fall loswerden möchte das
war ich freue mich dass ich dabei war
eine sehr witzige aktion ich habe auch
ein bisschen im wunderschönen bauen
können dass erfolg nicht selber weil ich
eigentlich selber dachte oder denke ich
bin nicht der mega hübsche bauer und ja
das freut mich eigentlich war ist ein
tolles projekt auch es ist viel zu schön
das wissen über ernste themen gesprochen
wird
da wird auch nicht nur der kreative
geist mit minecraft gefördert sondern
auch gezeigt dass man intelligentes um
das in der style zu sagen finde ich
super du brauchst du so schön ruhig mal
als kann einig dass kategorie vor
schlecht vor hier um wann und wieso es
in unserem täter so scheiße aus sagt das
einzige was macht das nicht die
blumentöpfe mit dem kaktus stehen ja die
sind so die akzente und der unter der
zaun und so und dann einfach das mit den
teppichen aber es sieht einfach gut aus
respekt man vor allem respekt einfach
nur das bisher beste haus hass und
schild bei märchen schild ich muss es ja
honorieren note ganz ganz geile der
länder aber ich hab noch holz lack ist
also achso und kartoffeln
auch die stone button sie harmonieren
hier einfach mehr sind aber keines der
button dessen holzbalken
mein thema du hast einfach keine ahnung
und ja ich wollte das einfach keine
rolle
10 level up date up domann ich dachte
ich da wächst ein paar gebratene
kartoffeln
ich wollte erst mal steht man kurz das
ist echt ich mehr nehme einfach so krass
viele und ich habe einfach wieder viel
zu viel gemacht so der natürlich so viel
und jetzt und luca klick doppelt so
viele rechte konzert geholfen aber des
wesens genau dass du hast schön geformt
und ich hab immer kleine spenden
erhalten das ist ganz viel liebe drin
hat wenn man hier unten im keller alles
klar
2 plus 2 christoph winck guter
durchschnitt aus von kesha besser als
das durchschnitt wird dadurch die drei k
du bist ja schon fast elite mein freund
mussten wir nur die die eins muss ich
mir einfach offen halten für wien so
richtig im mäßigen sache kommen das ist
schon sehr sehr geil ist oder in zwei
raten all diesen aus die brötchen in
texte packen
man kommt und hier so mega haus braucht
dann brauche ich noch die strippe zu dir
completely dann würde ich aber sagen ich
höre auf ich will dich das ist ein wald
fährt ich möchte die ganze sache
10 level sind viel mehr wert als das
ganze als er mir gegeben hat gar nicht
mehr tatenlos network wan 33 mit 1 reist
man vor langsam dazu aber niemals hier
gewesen genug junge ich brauche noch die
manche steine die ich noch nicht hatte
dann brauche ich noch einfacher ich lauf
noch mal zu der sand pyramide da links
und dann ist das möglich
ich möchte dass ein dass das komplette
so zu ist noch von dem stein paar und
von dem stein paar gehen wir jetzt noch
kurz denn so zum ende machen danach ein
ende
du schreibst gehe ich zum letzten mal
rein möchte nochmal meinen dank
aussprechen ist ein sehr gutes projekt
gefällt mir richtig gut
hast du schon zum 20 wenn es geil ist da
muss man das als sagen ein eisblock
nicht genug einmal geht noch ich konnte
mir passt muss das tor machen wo ich
kann ja ein paar löcher stopfen die so
traurig nochmal die letzte grimasse raus
die ich habe es doch so schön die
klassen ich hier so macht ihr noch
irgendeine abschlusssatz ihren oder
gehalt gute nacht noch im bett machen
noch ein bett noch ein bett noch rüstet
also wer bei mir zuschauer meinen meinen
dingens sieht wenn inventar das ist
schon krass aufgebaut
na ja gut dann würde ich einfach sagen
also ich muss mein wetter da oben ich
liege im bett ist es schon wieder tag
nicht es wird aber gerade der tag von
ich bin im bett gute nacht vielen dank
fürs anschauen dieser folge der nächste
gast steht schon fest und dann geht's in
zwei tagen weiter oder in einem tag mal
in zwei tagen nicht mag ist eine über
robert exporte in der wand jetzt weiter
kopf trifft das baden in der wand das
finde ich schwierig selbst um
auch schade nur fast wollen die köpfe
ein sehr guter gast mit einem
hervorragenden haus das beste bisher 30
noch force barcoo phoenix 1
ich würde sogar sagen höchstens
minecraft pocket hätten schlagen können
und dann besuchten besucht cavs kanal
schaut vorbei der macht glaube ich auch
diese diese displays
das gleiche gilt auch andersrum falls
ihr das weiterverfolgen will dieses
geile event hier oder da es ja gehen
durch den event einfach mal bei luca und
bei felix auf dem kanal vorbei alles
natürlich wie in der beschreibung